Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir unterbrechen unsere Kurzpass-Pause für ein bisschen Podcastlandschaftspflege. Ihr kennt es vielleicht schon vom jetzten Jahr. Ich begrüße jetzt wieder neben mir den Producer Jens Huiber vom Sportradio360.
Max, ich freue mich sehr, dass ich da sein darf. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ich da sein darf. Ich wusste natürlich, dass es Kurzpass-Pause gibt, aber dass du jetzt aus dem Refugium zurückkehrst extra wegen mir, das finde ich fantastisch.
Das muss so sein, denn hier geht es um etwas Größeres als nur den Rasenfunk. Es geht um ein unglaubliches Projekt, das du dir schon wieder aufgeheizt hast. Ich frage mich, wann und wie du das alles machst, aber du hast es wieder geschafft, 108 Seiten in ein Magazin zu pressen, mit so illustren Namen außen drauf, dass du das für 40 Euro am Bahnhof verkaufen könntest, in Gold gebunden und nicht so wie du, einfach nur paar... Wie viel kostet es? Komm, wir machen gleich den ganzen, woher kriegt man es gerade?
Okay, das Teil heißt Hashtag 12 Monate, wie schon im letzten Jahr, und pro Monat habe ich in diesem Jahr einen Euro veranschlagt, plus Versandkosten, also 12 Euro plus in Deutschland 1,55. Bestellen, Steilpass, Edge Sport Radio 360.de. Es ist ein Compendium wieder geworden über das Jahr 2019 mit lieben Freunden und Kollegen, die auch ansonsten in unserem Podcast dabei sind. Mir gefällt es sehr gut, aber es muss ja nicht dem Angler schmecken, sondern euch da draußen.
Ja, das wird es aber ziemlich sicher. Willst du noch vielleicht kurz das, was du eigentlich tust, bewerben? Nämlich Sportradio360. Erzähl uns doch mal, warum sollten wir, ich sage es ja den Hörern und Hörern immer wieder, dass sie Sportradio360 hören sollen. Die Big Show höre ich jede Woche. Ich bin immer stolz, wenn ich es am Freitagvormittag schon geschafft habe.
Das setzt mich natürlich unter Druck, wenn du mir jetzt noch mal sagst, dass du das anhörst. Ich glaube, wer sich nur für Eintracht Frankfurt interessiert, ist bei uns vielleicht nicht richtig aufgehoben. Aber wer sich für ein bisschen Sport-Show ähnlich, Olympia ähnlich, für mehrere Disziplinen interessiert, wir versuchen halt vieles abzubilden, was hauptsächlich mich interessiert und wo ich Zugang habe zu Journalisten, die sich mit diesen Themen auseinandersetzen. Das mag jetzt, weil der Max gerade hier sitzt, im Trikot nicht, aber im Sweater der Green Bay Packers. Wir haben natürlich immer sehr, sehr viele Teile, die sich um den American Sports kümmern, auch die NFL. Wir haben Tennis, wir haben jetzt wieder Alpinen, Skisport im Winter. Wir haben natürlich auch Fußball, klar, wir haben Motorsport und ich versuche, dich Leitathletik mit reinzubringen. Also Dinge, die man vielleicht jetzt hier in Specialty Podcasts nicht so sehr hört, das breite Kompendium. Deswegen könnte man uns vielleicht hören.
Genau, deswegen sollte man euch hören. Also für mich ist das nämlich, ich bin ja sehr fußballbezogen und muss ja irgendwie auch sehr fußballbezogen sein und für mich ist das quasi immer, also die Big Show ist immer der Blick, was passiert sonst noch und ich informiere mich tatsächlich über andere Sportarten hauptsächlich darüber und was soll ich sagen? Es funktioniert jetzt seit mehreren Jahren so gut, dass es nicht auffällt. Du kennst dich ja gar nicht, außer die Leute sagen eher, ach du guckst auch Formel 1 nicht, so ne seit Jahren nicht mehr, aber weißt halt, was da geht.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich so und ich habe jetzt Basketball zum Beispiel auch vergessen, aber das ist wirklich so über die BBL, wenn man bei uns mit Stefan, wenn Stefan Koch was erzählt oder Michael Körner was erzählt, dann weißt du plötzlich, warum es in Ulm nicht läuft. Und ich wusste es nicht, ich sehe Ergebnisse in Ulm, ich sage, Körni, warum läuft es in Ulm nicht? Und Michael Körner erklärt das in einem Satz, weil die einfach Probleme auf der Point Guard Position haben. Das ist das Einzige, was ich beim Basketball glaube ich noch erkennen würde, wer spielt Point Guard? Und Körni erklärt mir das und jetzt weiß ich, ja, okay. Und deshalb sollte man bei uns reinhören, weil wir eben viele Dinge, wir haben viel über Rugby gesprochen, auch mit Jan Lüdecke, der das ja kommentiert hat. Jan hat auch hier in diesem Magazin was geschrieben. Also, ja, ich glaube, das ist der Ansatz, den wir verfolgen, der vielleicht ein kleines bisschen einzigartig ist. Seit 2011.
Eben, absolut. Das ist schon sehr lange mit dabei. Erste G-Versuche 2005 schon.
Michael Leopold, Markus Gaub, Michael Körner, Markus Grabingkling im Schatten des Leierkastens. Wer sich auskennt in München, weiß, wo das ungefähr ist.
Gugelt es.
Ja, bitte, googelt den Leierkasten. Sie kommen als Fremder und gehen als Freund.
Okay, und jetzt hast du dir gedacht, die Weltherrschaft von Sportradio360, sie muss zementiert werden in einem Print-Produkt, weil das ist die Zukunft.
Das ist die Zukunft.
Und das ist ja tatsächlich auch die Art, wie man dich unterstützen kann über diese Dinge, die du immer wieder machst.
Gerne. Digital ist tot, wissen wir beide. Also Print ist die Zukunft. Und wir haben es ja letztes Jahr schon gemacht. Auch deine Hörer haben dankenswerterweise zugegriffen. Ich habe die Auflage in diesem Jahr ein bisschen erhöht, weil ich... Zauber! Ja, also ich habe sie nicht verdreifacht, aber es gab doch mehrere Leute, die gesagt haben, ich habe sie bei Max gehört, habe ein bisschen zu spät da bestellt, aber das sollte in diesem Jahr nicht der Fall sein. Trotzdem bestellt bitte früh und gerne. Es sind schon ein paar weg.
Sehr gut. Jetzt hast du noch ein bisschen Fear of Missing Out, ein bisschen FOMO gestreut. Genau, und es ist eben dein Finanzierungsmodell so ein bisschen, oder zumindest dein Unterstützermodell.
Genau, also wer uns so wie den Max direkt unterstützen möchte, gerne. Aber hier die Geschichte, wer dieses Magazin bestellt, trägt zumindest dazu bei, dass die Fotokosten und Printkosten gedeckt sind. Also da bin ich bald so weit und wenn es ein bisschen drüber hinausgeht, dann...
Es soll definitiv drüber hinausgehen. Also, lass uns rein gehen. Du musst mich jetzt durchführen, durch die Highlights. Das letzte Mal haben wir glaube ich jeden Artikel einfach einmal kurz angesprochen.
Das wollen wir dieses Mal vielleicht nicht zwingend machen, aber es geht gleich wie ich finde mit einem Highlight los, weil eben Thomas Wagner sich mit einem Kumpel begeben hat nach Uruguay. Und Thomas Wagner, ich habe mit ihm voriges Jahr eine Autofahrt bestritten von München nach Kitzbühel. Es ist nerdig gewesen von der ersten Minute an, aber großartig.
Warum hast du das nicht aufgezeichnet?
Hätte ich machen müssen, ja. Also Thomas und wir sprachen dann sofort über den WM-Kader Österreichs 1982.
Gott, es ist gut, dass du es nicht aufgezeichnet hast.
Pass auf, und er konnte aber mehr Österreicher nennen als ich. Er hat sich an Josef D. Georgi erinnert, den ich schon erfolgreich verdrängt hatte, völlig mit Recht. Ja, und Thomas hat sich aufgemacht nach Uruguay und hat in der ihm sehr eigenen Art diese Reise zum Beispiel geschildert. Also es ist ein Must-Read, wie der Uruguayer sagt, es ist fantastisch. Er hat einen Kumpel dabei gehabt, sind auch beide abgebildet. Ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt in seinem Sinne war, dass ich seinen Kumpel mit abbilde, aber das ist ganz groß. Also wirklich sehr, sehr schön. Also Fußball hat auch hier, spielt die Hauptrolle in diesem kleinen Machwerk. Wir haben, lass uns vielleicht zu den Fußballern ganz kurz was sagen. Es wird gelitten auch und es wird schön gelitten. Axel Goldmann, den du ja auch gut kennst.
Ganz herzliche Grüße.
Axel leidet sehr mit dem FC und hat auch was drüber geschrieben, aber auch unser gemeinsamer Freund Florian Regelmann von spox.com. Florian, der natürlich mit dem VfB Stuttgart mit abgestiegen ist und ich meine, nicht damit rechnet, jemals wieder aufzusteigen. Und Florian hat auch etwas geschrieben über den VfB. Es ist fantastisch. Dann haben wir einen Aufsteiger drinnen, Franz Büchner, der als Union Berlin-Fan natürlich niemals mehr dran geglaubt hatte, der sich in dieser Nische Zweite Liga unfassbar wohlgefühlt hat. Aber der Franz ist mit Union Berlin aufgestiegen und zeichnet so ein kleines bisschen den Weg auch nach von Union Berlin.
Der erste Satz im Artikel vom Regelfloh. Ich konnte leider noch nicht reinschauen, unter anderem wegen der Pause. Der erste Satz, es ist kein gutes Zeichen, wenn deine Mutter mit dir zusammen ein Spiel des VfB anschaut. Ach, meine Güte. Er ist ja auch ein Freund dieses Hauses. Die Folgen mit ihm sind legendär inzwischen schon. Da hat er unter anderem auch den Satz gesagt. Ich bin gespannt, ob ich das hier wiederfinde in diesem Artikel. Er hat unter anderem gesagt, vom Anspruch her gehört der VfB Stuttgart in die Champions League.
Ja, lest einfach rein. Aber das ist natürlich der Anspruch, den auch der 1. FC Köln hat. Machen wir uns nichts vor. Machen wir uns nichts vor.
Wobei die hassen das ja, wenn man das sagt.
Ja, Florian Regelmann, was wir natürlich über Flo wissen, wo es niemand, nicht einmal die Mutter von Andy Murray, mehr als Flo Regelmann liebt. Das möchte man vorausschicken.
Aber womit? Mit Recht?
Ja, natürlich, selbstverständlich mit Recht.
Aber das habt ihr ja auch schon besprochen, die Frage nach dem, warum muss das jetzt nochmal sein? Aber mit diesem Turniersieg, das war halt jetzt schon nochmal...
Da ist die Hüfte gleich ein bisschen leichter geworden, bei Regelmann und bei Murray, in beiden Fällen. Ich glaube, außerordentlich ist in diesem Heft auch, und ich lobe nicht mich, sondern ich lobe die Autoren, das zwei eingefleischte Fans und wirklich Fans, Journalisten zwar aber schon Fans des glorreichen SV Werder Bremen, sich zwei Ikonen des nicht minder glorreichen, manche sagen sogar glorreicheren, FC Bayern Münchens angenommen haben. Und das eine ist Jürgen Schmider von der Süddeutschen Zeitung, der ja in den USA lebt, dessen Frau übrigens für das Titelbild verantwortlich ist. Zum Titelbild möchte ich gleich noch was sagen. Gerne. Aber Jürgen hat sich um Bastian Schweinsteiger, um dessen Abschied gekümmert. Da gibt es einen Artikel von Jürgen, der mit nichts anderem übertitelt ist, und wie ich finde, auch wieder mit Recht, einfach nur Chef. Weil Bastian Schweinsteiger das einfach verkörpert hat und auch dann in seiner Zeit in Chicago. Und der andere ist natürlich einer meiner journalistischen Säulenheiligen. Das ist Holger Gertz, der ja auch grün-weiß in der Wolle gefärbt ist, wie man so unschön sagt. Und er hat sich um Uli Hoeneß gekümmert und hat ein abschließendes Wort zu Uli Hoeneß gesprochen. Und das ist, wie man es bei Holger halt kennt, weder schwarz noch weiß, sondern sehr differenziert ausgefallen. Weil Uli Hoeneß, das weißt du natürlich als großer Sympathisant des FC Bayern München, es ist nicht schwarz und nicht. Es ist zwar viel schwarz und viel weiß, aber es vermischt sich dann irgendwie zu einem undefinierbaren Grauton.
Die sogenannte Lichtgestalt, sie strahlt gräulich. Und das kann man auch über die eigentliche Lichtgestalt sagen.
Genau, die irgendwie nicht mehr strahlt in letzter Zeit, finde ich.
Die aber auch nicht mehr strahlen möchte, damit man gewisse Fragen nicht mehr stellt. Aber das sagt ja schon alles über das Prinzip Sportradio360. Du bist jemand, der 2011 einen Podcast gestartet hat, der fast täglich Folgen veröffentlicht, der allein eben jeden Donnerstag ab 17 Uhr über drei Stunden in der Regel raushaut zum Sportenwochenende. Und dann schreiben eben einfach Leute wie Holger Gertz nochmal zu Uli Hoeneß, was eben sonst auf einer Seite 3 landet in der SZ. Das finde ich schon bemerkt.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was es mit Holger und mir ist, aber uns verbindet eine gemeinsame Liebe zu Wien. Wenn ich mich mit Holger austausche, dann hauptsächlich über Wien. Und ich habe ihn mal ganz zart angefragt. Es ist so, wenn ich das sagen darf, Max, und ich sage es einfach. Und da warst du auch dabei und du warst auch im letzten Jahr dabei. Und ich hoffe natürlich schwer auf dich im nächsten Jahr wieder.
Ja, wenn es hoffentlich nicht genau in meine ich trete etwas kurze Phase fällt, dann bin ich auch gerne dabei.
Aber wir haben ja mit dir gemeinsam auch ein WM-Magazin gemacht. Und da hat Holger auch geschrieben. Und Holger hat sich da, ich weiß ja, Holger liebt die Österreicher und Holger liebt auch Ernst Happel oder liebte Ernst Happel. Und Holger hat dort einen Vergleich angestellt zwischen Ernst Happel und Cesar Luis Menotti anlässlich des WM-Finales 1978. Und Holger hat halt auch in jeder Seite drei, er hat zwei Sätze drin, die ganz einfach sind, aber die jemand wie ich niemals schreiben könnte. Und wenn es nur der Satz ist, was nicht gegen ihn spricht. Und wenn Holger baut diese Sätze so ein, dass ich mir denke, Wahnsinn, wieso komme ich auf sowas nicht drauf? Ich schreibe ja auch, auch beruflich schreibe ich, aber das könnte ich nicht. Und bei Holger passt das Timing, bei Holger passt, es ist auch die Einfachheit, von der Holger lebt. Und dieses WM-Magazin, also wenn es wem interessiert, wie der Wiener sagt, Achtung, absichtlich falsch verwendeter Dativ. Ich habe noch ungefähr 200 Stück zu Hause. Ehrlich? Sagt einfach oder schreibt einfach dazu, zum Sonder-Occasionspreis von, keine Ahnung, 4 Euro, ihr kriegt das WM-Magazin dazu. Wer es haben möchte, es ist lesenswert, es ist optisch nicht ganz so gelungen wie diese 12 Monate.
Aber es ist wirklich gut.
Aber allein der Artikel von Max, der über... Doch, doch, du hast über jemanden geschrieben, dessen Kinder ich unterrichtet habe. Mehr möchte ich nicht sagen. Ein sehr, sehr ruhiger, aber fußballerisch großer, ein Mann, der Luca Toni groß herausgebracht hat, ist meine These.
Weißt du, was ich getan habe in diesem Artikel? Es war der letztmögliche Zeitpunkt, diesen Bericht zu schreiben über diese Person. Denn ich habe das Fußballbuch des Jahres 2020 antizipiert. Nicht, dass ich es geschrieben hätte, by far not. Aber es wurde inzwischen veröffentlicht. Inzwischen weiß ich auch, dass der Autor da sehr lange schon ran saß. Und dass dieses Buch sehr empfehlenswert ist. Ja, aber nicht für 4 Euro raushauen. Ich würde sagen, ein 20er.
Für beide.
Genau.
Steilpass edsportradio360.de jetzt bestellen.
Das ist ja unglaublich, dass du die noch hast. Aber um kurz darauf einzugehen, das wird jetzt einfach so eine... Das wird eine Werbesitzung. Ja, aber im sonst werbefreien Rasenfunk können die Leute ja ausschalten. Aber das, was du erzählt hast mit den Sätzen von Holger Gerz, das ist genau der Grund, warum ich nicht mehr Printjournalismus mache. Oder generell der schreibenden Zunft angehöre. Weil ich das bei Freunde auch gesehen habe, dass es einfach Leute gibt, die ein Talent haben für eben Timing, für Wortfindungen, eben für das Einfache oft, das ich nicht habe. Und das ist auch wirklich deine Talentfrage. Das kannst du mit Fleiß nicht wettmachen. Ich hab dann trotzdem keine schlechten Artikel geschrieben, aber ihnen hat das Geniale gefehlt. Es war nie genial. Meine Artikel waren immer gut, glaube ich. Aber sie waren nie genial. Und im Live-Ticker habe ich es manchmal geschafft. Das ist ja dann so quasi auch so eine Art Kunstform. Da habe ich es manchmal geschafft. Da war ich auch immer sehr stolz, wenn ich dann so... Das merkst du ja erst, wenn du es drei Monate später liest, ob es wirklich okay war oder nicht. Oder an den Reaktionen manchmal, wenn dir Leute auf deren Meinung du was gibst, da Rückmeldung geben. Aber das Geniale hat gefehlt. Das war dann eine sehr frustrierende Erkenntnis, dass ich gemerkt habe, ein gewisses Level werde ich leider nie erreichen. Ich werde durch meinen Ehrgeiz immer nicht schlecht sein, aber ich werde nie dieses Level erreichen. Und ich werde aber immer sehen, dass da was fehlt. Und deswegen habe ich mich dann dafür entschieden, okay, gut, dann ist das, glaube ich, nicht das, was ich machen möchte. Weil dann bin ich ja in 20 Jahren völlig deprimiert. Weil ich jetzt 20 Jahre lang diesen genialen Schreiberlingen hinterher eifere.
Das ist eben die Geschichte, wenn du Ticker ansprichst, der Gieselmann, der Gieselmann, diese WM-Ticker, die der für die Süddeutsche geschrieben hat, die war natürlich auch gespickt dann mit YouTube-Videos, mit ein bisschen Social Media dann auch zusätzlich. Das war so gut, dass ich auch weiß, sowas werde ich nicht erreichen. Und um hier vielleicht den Bogen zu schließen, ich habe hier auch einen Artikel geschrieben über meinen Sohn im Grunde genommen, den ich natürlich über alles liebe und der sich im Sommer im Rahmen eines Events in einer Art und Weise großartig verhalten hat, dass ich darüber schreiben musste. Und ich habe dem Jürgen Schmider diesen Artikel gegeben, sagt Jürgen, lies ihn bitte mal durch. Und Jürgen hat diesen Artikel dann zerlegt in einer Art und Weise. Er hat gesagt, es ist gut, aber. Dann hat er gesagt, das muss anders werden, das, das, das, das musst du anders schreiben. Und ich gehe davon aus, dass das bei einer Zeitung wie der Süddeutschen Zeitung täglich gang und gäbe ist. Und das könnte ich nicht. Dass mir der Chefredakteur Sport, Klaus Hölzenbein, der das natürlich kann, sonst wäre er nicht Chefredakteur, aber dass der jeden Tag meinen Artikel zerpflückt und natürlich will er mir damit helfen, aber ich hätte die Ausdauer nicht.
Ja, also daran gewöhnt man sich. Das kann ich aus eigener Erfahrung sagen. Am Anfang kriegst du es halt komplett rot gefärbt zurück und dann irgendwann bekommst du aber auch ein Gefühl dafür. Später gibt es dann noch so eine Phase, wo du dann festest, manchmal sind es dann nur Stilfragen. Also es gibt die schlechteren Chefredakteure oder Textchefs, die wollen, dass jeder Artikel so klingt, als hätten sie ihn geschrieben und die besseren lassen dir trotzdem deinen eigenen Stil, aber helfen dir, den zu verfeinern. Das habe ich dann irgendwann später dann in der Beobachtung bei Neon zum Beispiel ganz gut beobachten können, mit einem ganz herausragenden Textchef. Daran gewöhnt man sich, aber trotzdem, es ist wenig so harte Arbeit, wie zu schreiben. Wenig ist so schlimm, wie sich vor ein weißes Blatt Papier zu setzen. Du leidest unglaublich und du bist nie zufrieden. Du denkst dir immer, ja okay, es passt schon. Genau, und dann bekommst du auch immer zurück gemeldet. Du, es hätte halt auch noch besser sein können. Aber du kommst dann an irgendeinen Punkt nicht mehr weiter. Ich weiß noch, irgendwann hatte ich mal eine Diskussion über die Verwendung von Adjektiven mit der Giesemann tatsächlich. Und weil ich immer sehr viel, ich hatte immer lustige Metaphern in meinen Texten, weil ich auch dachte, so ein bisschen Humor muss halt einfach in jedem Text sein. Find ich einfach immer selber immer ganz gut. Und dann liegt es natürlich dann im Auge des Betrachters und der Betrachterin, ob es auch lustig war. Und dann haben wir uns über die Verwendung von Adjektiven unterhalten, weil halt oft du dann ein Adjektiv brauchst, um quasi etwas humoristisch zu überspitzen oder eben klein zu reden. Und dann hat er mir gesagt, das beste Adjektiv ist das nicht verwendete. Und da habe ich... Das hat er mir 2008 gesagt. Und ich habe es mir bis heute gemerkt. Und tatsächlich, wenn man dann darauf achtet, jetzt habe ich zum Beispiel das Wort tatsächlich verwendet, soll ich nicht so oft sagen, da regen sich manche Höre auf.
Auch Gaub sagt oft tatsächlich, habe ich mir jetzt auch mal gesagt.
Ich finde, gerade hat jemand bei YouTube geschrieben, das schlimmste Füllwort des Jahres.
Tatsächlich?
Tatsächlich hat er damit wahrscheinlich recht, aber es ist anscheinend etwas, was sich in unseren Sprachgebrauch eingeschlichen hat. Aber auf jeden Fall, wenn man dann darauf achtet, ist es tatsächlich so, dass die richtig, richtig guten Texte die erzeugen, das, was man sonst mit Adjektiven erzeugt, nämlich das Beschreibende und dass man eben dem Leser und der Leserin quasi im Grunde sagt, wie hast du das jetzt zu verstehen, was ich gerade beschreibe, die schaffen das tatsächlich ohne Adjektive.
Wenn man mal drauf achtet, da muss man drauf achten. weil du sagst, ein weißes Blatt oder eine weiße Screen, weißes Word-Dokument ist das Allerschlimmste, das hat mir die Saskia Leite auch so gesagt. Es geht ja bei jedem Artikel so. Die Saskia hat, ich habe sie gebeten, dass sie mir vielleicht irgendwas über die Biathlon WM in Oestersund schreibt oder dort war sie ja, da tat sie auch für die Süddeutsche, wie ich finde, also täglich auch sehr humoristisch über den, ist es der schwedische Königssohn, der sich da zu viele Kalorien reinschmeißt und Saskia hat eben hier was über Laura Dahlmeier geschrieben, zum Beispiel, aber auch Saskia sagt, es ist halt jeder Text, wenn er gut werden muss. Es ist schon Arbeit, harte Arbeit und eine Qual. Aber das, was rauskommt bei Saskia, ist wie immer fantastisch. So und jetzt zum Titelbild.
Zum Titelbild.
Max.
Du musst es beschreiben.
Ich muss es beschreiben, so. Und Saskia hat völlig richtig gesagt, hat mir gesagt persönlich, eine Frau hätte nicht geschadet, womit sie völlig recht hat natürlich, die große Saskia erleitet. Aber, so. Es ist ein Potpourri, all dessen, was man in diesem Heft findet. Wir haben Virgil van Dijk zum Beispiel auf diesem Titelbild, weil der fantastische Francois du Château, die Elftal, der Holländer Francois, von A bis Z beschreibt. Die Renaissance. Jetzt denke ich mir natürlich, wenn Holland zu Hause gegen Nordirland verloren hätte, was jetzt gar nicht mal so unwahrscheinlich gewesen wäre, hätte Francois vielleicht das A bis Z anders formulieren müssen. Aber, es hat sich keine Frau auf das Titelbild gefunden. Warum? Ich hatte Constanze Klosterhalven auf dem Schirm, weil ich wusste, dass Johannes Knud etwas über die Leichtathletik WM schreiben wird. Wir haben dieses Titelbild aber sehr früh in Auftrag gegeben, bei Hanni Schmider und ich war mir nicht sicher, ob jetzt Johannes was schreibt, über Klosterhalven oder über jemand anderen. Und Johannes hat dann tatsächlich, und dieser Artikel ist absolut lesenswert, weil liebe Fußballfreunde da draußen, ich weiß bei Max werdet ihr in erster Linie über Fußball bedient, aber Johannes beschreibt einen jungen Mann, der aus meiner Sicht das Potenzial hat, einer der größten deutschen Sportstars der nächsten zehn Jahre zu werden. Und er kann es nur werden, weil er eine österreichische Mutter hat, machen wir uns nichts. Es ist der Zehnkampf-Weltmeister, Niklas Kaul, der eine unfassbare Coolness ausstrahlt, schon obwohl er erst, ich glaube, 21 Jahre alt ist. Der natürlich jetzt in Doha davon profitiert hat, dass der große französische Favorit Kevin Maillard früh ausgeschieden ist. Aber Johannes beschreibt diesen Niklas Kaul und es ist lesenswert, der Typ ist, der Johannes sowieso auch, aber auch Niklas Kaul, den muss man verfolgen, auch wenn die Zehnkämpfer vielleicht nur zwei, drei Wettkämpfe pro Jahr haben. Der ist so tiefenentspannt, der ist, wie er es macht, der ist ästhetisch, der ist ein unfassbar guter Speerwerfer, was ich nicht wusste. Und den beschreibt eben Johannes. Aber aufs Titelblatt, zum Glück haben wir jetzt Constanze Klosterhalven nicht drauf genommen, weil was wäre das gewesen, wenn dann kein Artikel über sie stattfindet. Also bitte, liebe Damen da draußen, überhaupt nicht. Gerne. Und gerne Berichte, Artikel über Damen. Wir haben eben ein bisschen was über Angie Kerber, wir haben was über Laura Dahlmeier, aber Constanze Klosterhalven hat es eben nicht geschafft. Das ist mehr Kulper, ich geisle mich selbst. Max sagt zu mir auch immer, Jens, du brauchst mehr Frauen in deinem Programm, und mit der völlig Recht hat, selbstverständlich, werde ich Max im privaten Gespräch noch erklären.
Es ist ein Erfolgskonzept, Jens.
Es ist ein oder kein?
Es ist ein Erfolgskonzept, ich kann es dir sagen. Es macht alles besser.
Natürlich macht es alles besser. So, Max, aber jetzt muss ich mich hier rechtfertigen. Nein, ich möchte mich. Was ist die Idee gewesen von Sportradio360? Es war nie die Idee, dass ich da auch nur einen Satz sage, jemals. Sondern ich wollte, dass Leute, die es gelernt haben wie Andreas Renner, wie Wolfoos, wie Marco Hagemann, dass die meine Moderatoren sind. Aber die haben natürlich jetzt nicht alle jede Woche Zeit gehabt. Und meine Gäste sollten Moderatoren, Kommentatoren sein von Sky, da sagen, da gab es damals nicht Eurosport, RTL, Sport1, DSF damals. Oder Journalisten oder Journalistinnen der Süddeutschen Zeitung. Und jetzt schauen wir mal, wie viele Kommentatoren, Kommentatorinnen gibt es bei Sky, da sagen Eurosport, RTL und Sport1, 0. Null. Und bei der Süddeutschen Zeitung gibt es fünf Redakteurinnen. Das eine ist die Frau Pochhammer. Reitsport interessiert mich nicht so sehr. Anna Dreher, die werde ich und möchte ich anfragen.
Fantastisch.
Die ist fantastisch. Birgit Schöner habe ich angefragt, hat keine Zeit. Und Barbara Klimke werde ich wieder anfragen. Die hatte bei der letzten Anfrage keine Zeit. Fürs Eiskunstlauf. Und ansonsten, die Saskia ist so oft, ich kann... Also es ist ein schwieriges Thema. Ich weiß, mehr Kulper.
Ja, das ist ganz interessant, weil wir stehen dann im Grunde an verschiedenen Enden der, ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal Industrie. Und zwar du nutzt quasi das, was aus der Industrie rausfällt, nämlich die etablierten Journalistinnen, Journalisten und Kommentatorinnen und Kommentatoren. Und da ist eben einfach die Quote noch sehr schlecht. Und ich versuche eben, aber halt auch weil es ein anderer Ansatz ist, ich versuche eben auch Leute, die vorher noch nie in einem Podcast waren, die noch nie in einem Mikro gesprochen haben, kommen, lass es uns mal ausprobieren. Und das mache ich mit Männern wie mit Frauen. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich da, will mich jetzt nicht hinstellen, wie der Typ der Frauen an die Hand nimmt. Quatsch, ich mache das einfach mit ganz vielen Leuten, dass ich sage, mich würde deine Meinung interessieren, lass uns das ausprobieren, vielleicht ist das was für dich. Und da gibt es dann eben tollerweise dann sowohl bei Männern als auch bei Frauen dann viele, die irgendwie so ein bisschen dabei bleiben, die so ein bisschen Blut geleckt haben. Ich meine, du kennst es ja auch, man kann dann irgendwann nicht mehr aufhören zu reden über Sport und vielleicht schiebt man so dann in einer sehr langen Welle dann Leute in die Industrie ja sogar auch rein.
Und vielleicht muss ich meinen Ansatz ja auch neu definieren in den nächsten 16 Jahren.
Also es ist ein sehr höhnischer Ansatz, sich so auf die Süddeutsche Zeitung, also auf die süddeutsche Presse zu konzentrieren.
Ja, aber weil Manuel Neuer nie feiert. Ich bin ja bekanntermaßen kein FC Bayern-Fan. Und das ist für mich völlig in Ordnung. Die Süddeutsche nicht, sagt Manuel Neuer, darf konkurrenzlos bis ins Jahr 2027 im deutschen Fußballnationalteam spielen.
Eine alberne Diskussion. Wollen wir sie nicht wieder aufwärmen? Was gibt es noch zu lesen? Weil wir sprechen, ich würde sagen, wir haben ein Achtel des Heftes jetzt angesprochen und trotzdem schon 13 gute Gründe da reinzulesen.
Na gut, also mein Steckenpferd ist natürlich der alpine Skisport. Da haben wir Tom Heberlein vom SED. Hat Felix Neurauter nochmal gewürdigt, der eigentlich in Deutschland immer Sportler des Jahres sein sollte, weil er quasi eine Person war. Und es gibt dann auch noch von Roman Stelzen, lieber Freund von der Tiroler Tageszeit. Und er hat so ein kleines bisschen darauf geschaut, was hat sich geändert durch diese vielen Rücktritte im alpinen Ski-Weltcup. Marcel Hirscher ist zurückgetreten, Axel Lünzwinder, Lindsey Vonn auf der Damenseite. Und das muss man lesen. Auch wer sich für den alpinen Skisport sagt, es ist ein österreichisches Ding und ein süddeutsches Ding, lese es bitte trotzdem, es ist großartig. Dann, und jetzt muss ich sagen, Mea Culper, wer das Heft jetzt noch nicht bestellt hat, die große Gefahr besteht, dass es nicht bestellt wird, wenn der Huiber jetzt sagt, ich sympathisiere mit Rasenball Leipzig und mit Red Bull Salzburg. Aus Gründen, die nicht nachvollziehbar sind für euch da draußen, die ihr alle Puristen seid. Aber ich mag den amerikanischen Sport gern und ich finde, das ist halt einfach eine klassische amerikanische Organisation, wo es einen Owner gibt, der das bestmögliche Produkt rausholt.
Und auch ein zweifelhafter Owner.
Also die politische Einstellung von Herrn Matyschitz teile ich zu, ich glaube, einem halben Prozent möglicherweise, aber das ist schon ein bisschen hochgegriffen. Aber Martin Konrad hat über Jesse Marsh, den Coach von Red Bull Salzburg, einen Artikel geschrieben, der großartig ist. Weil Jesse Marsh, der war ja zuerst Co-Trainer in Leipzig, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist seit diesem Jahr Chef-Coach in Salzburg, hat mit Erling Haaland einen Spieler unter seinen Fittichen, der im kommenden Jahr garantiert nicht mehr in Salzburg spielen wird. Ich glaube auch nicht in der Bundesliga. Ich glaube, wir werden ihn eher in der Premier League sehen.
Es gibt wohl keine Ahnung, wie das passieren könnte im Vertrag, eine Ausstiegsklausel exklusiv nach Leipzig. Ich weiß nicht, wie die unbedingt auf Leipzig gekommen sind. Ich weiß auch nicht. Es ist manchmal, der Fußball geht manchmal seltsame Wege. Also das heißt, vielleicht sehen wir ihn sogar in der Bundesliga.
Ja, und das ist wirklich schön geschrieben von Martin. Dann, um den Bogen zu spannen zu deinem Outfit. Wir haben zwei Artikel. Es gibt auch Football in Deutschland, liebe American Football-Fans. Und Nicolas Martin, der ja auch bei mir schon fast mehr Arbeit leistet für Sportradio360 als ich, der jetzt gerade in den USA unterwegs ist, hat eben über einen der herausragendsten Quarterbacks der letzten Jahre in der GFL über Casey Terrio geschrieben, unbedingt lesen. Auf der anderen Seite Christian Schimmel hat über einen anderen Quarterback, der ganz große Probleme hatte in den USA im College und dann in der GFL aber irgendwie Fuß gefasst hat, was geschrieben über Silas Nazita. Fantastisch. Marco Hagemann, unser gemeinsamer Freund. Um wieder ganz kurz auf den Fußball zu kommen. Ich habe gesagt, Marco, du kennst den Jürgen Klopp so gut, wie hat sich die Beziehung entwickelt, hat Marco beschrieben. Motorsport, ja, du sagst es, Formel 1 in meiner Big Show, in unserer Big Show, Stefan Heinrich, eine Legende, war in Monza, hat über Monza, über dieses Wochenende, wo Charlie Claire gewonnen hat, über diesen Wahnsinn, wir haben es im Fernsehen gesehen, das war einer der wenigen Grand Prixs, die ich wirklich gesehen habe. Und was da abgegangen ist, dann auf der Stadtsiel geraten, mit diesen ganzen Tifosi, großartig, gleich zu Beginn des Heftes, was Trauriges. Wir haben im letzten Jahr, komischerweise am Ende des Jahres, mit Stefan Ehlen, mit Stefan Heinrich, mit Christian Nimmervoll, so meine Motorsportrunde, haben wir über Charlie Lamb gesprochen, über eine BMW-Legende. Und der war damals noch bester Gesundheit. Und Charlie Lamb ist komplett überraschend für alle Beteiligten Anfang des Jahres gestorben. Wirklich wie aus dem Nichts von einem Tag zum anderen. Und Stefan Ehlen würdigt ihn eben, auch die Wichtigkeit, die er für BMW, für den Motorsport ganz generell gehabt hat. Das ist, man muss jetzt nicht weinen, aber wenn man das so ein kleines bisschen wirklich komplett aus dem Leben gerissen von einem Tag aus dem anderen, und der Motorsport hat getrauert, wir trauern ein kleines bisschen mit hier über den Stefan Ehlen.
Das war auch damals sehr toll bei euch besprochen. Also man hat allen Beteiligten angemerkt, wie überraschend das kam, auch für die Journalisten, die näher dran waren. Aber da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Ich kannte ihn nicht, und ich hab in den, und Stefan schickt mir dann Bilder auch zum Artikel, die auf dem Artikel drin sind. Ich hatte mich Charlie Lamb viel älter vorgestellt, weißt du? Und dann sieht man dieses Bild von jemandem, der vielleicht drei Jahre optisch älter ist als ich und denkt sich, Wahnsinn, kann nicht sein. Über Toto Wolf gibt es was, der ein Menschenfreund ist, was ich so auch nicht wusste, den Mercedes-Chef. Wir haben Tennis drinnen, ja, mein Thema, mein Hauptthema neben Alpine im Skisport. Paul Heuser ist von Skyz ein ganz großer Fan, ist vielleicht falsch, aber Marc-Alexanders Wehrf sehr gern hat mitgelitten mit Alexander Wehrf. In diesem Jahr, wir haben Andre Antic, den Chefredakteur des Tennis-Magazins, der über dieses unfassbare Wimbledon-Finale nochmal ein paar Worte verliert. Max schaut schon zurecht auf die Uhr. Wir haben Basketballtrainer Stefan Koch, Coach Koch. Dann haben wir Andre Vogt, der natürlich diese schwierige Personalie, und das sollte ja wirklich alle Deutschen interessieren, Dennis Schröder noch mal ein kleines bisschen beleuchtet. Diese Schizophrenie, die bei Dennis natürlich herrscht, auf der einen Seite das, was er kann und deswegen ist Dennis natürlich auch auf dem Titelbild, das, was ihn auch auszeichnet als Spieler, dass er eben eine Führungsrolle einnimmt, aber dass das eben ganz, ganz schwierig war bei der Basketball-WM in China, dass das auch kolossal in die Hose gegangen ist am Ende des Tages mit seiner Führungsrolle. Das hat Ray noch mal aufgezeichnet. Septomito hat ein kleines bisschen eine andere, man möchte sagen tragische Gestalt unter die Lupe genommen, nämlich Kevin Durant, der sich ja apropos Achilles-Szene, die Achilles-Szene gerissen hat und in dieser Spielzeit wahrscheinlich gar nicht für die Brooklyn Nets spielen wird.
Und das Apropos bezieht sich auf unser Vorgespräch. Also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr habt nichts verpasst.
Apropos, ja, mit der Achilles-Szene, die dann gerissen ist. Ja, und ansonsten, ein bisschen Handball haben wir auch drin von Sascha Starr, der ja auch einen eigenen, zwei eigenen Podcasts mittlerweile hat. Ich hab Jan de Wit, das ist ein Tennistrainer von Nikolaus Basilaschwil, der aber sehr eng mit Werder Bremen auch zusammenarbeitet. Habe ich mal ein paar Fragen gestellt zu Florian Kohfeldt. Und Florian Kohfeldt scheint auf der anderen Seite, auch wenn die Tabelle im Moment vielleicht was anderes aussagt, aber ein richtig guter Trainer zu sein, aber noch ein viel, viel besserer Typ. Und das, ja, das runnert es einfach ab und apropos abrunden, das Jan Lüdecke hatte ich vorhin angesprochen. Jan Lüdecke hat über, das möchte ich allen, die im süddeutschen Raum leben, vielleicht ans Herz legen, Jan Lüdecke hat den Stadionsprecher gegeben bei den Rugby-Sevens während des Oktoberfestes. Oktoberfest-Sevens. Das ist eine wunderbare Veranstaltung, die aber, wo wir wirklich darauf hoffen müssen, dass im nächsten und übernächsten Jahr mehr Leute kommen, weil sonst steht ihr auf der Kippe. Geht bitte hin. Es ist toll, ich kannte das auch nicht, diese Rugby-Sevens, die spielen. Das ist unheimlich schnell, dieses Spiel. Es ist wahnsinnig anstrengend für alle Beteiligten. Und da hat Jan darüber was geschrieben. Und der Rausschmeißer in diesem Jahr ist vom fantastischen Thomas Hahn, der auch öfter früher über Leichtathletik in der Big Show zu hören war. Thomas Hahn, der jetzt in Tokio ist für die Süddeutsche Zeitung. Nächstes Jahr natürlich auch die Olympischen Spiele begleiten wird. Aber Thomas Hahn hat sich die sechs, sieben, acht Wochen Wahnsinn der Rugby WM gegeben und hat, darf man ohne Scheiß sagen in deiner Sendung, er hat jedenfalls unmittelbar nach Abpfiff der Rugby WM, hat er sich noch hingesetzt und hat hier 10.000 Zeichen runtergeklopft und hat gesagt, so jetzt muss er sich hinlegen, aber das noch für dich Jens und das rundert es ab und was soll ich sagen, ich bin ewig dankbar allen, die daran teilgenommen haben, auch dir Max, dass ich jetzt hier das Ganze promoten darf.
Das ist selbstverständlich. Ich habe einen Wunsch und eine Frage. Was möchtest du zuerst?
Die Frage bitte.
Die Frage. Als du gesagt hast, der größte deutsche Sportler und wir dann über Niklas Kau gesprochen haben, da fiel mir sofort Leon Dreiseitel ein und damit verbunden die Frage, das habt ihr früher gemacht, das ist jetzt glaube ich auch schon Jahre her, dass ihr das Ranking hattet.
Die Top Ten, die Power-Rankings.
Und das fand ich sensationell, weil das meinen Blick einfach geweiht hat. Ich bin Fußballidiot, ich kenne mich im Fußball viel aus, ich vergesse immer die Namen von...
Ab Wichschof 435 nächste Woche gibt es wieder...
Nee, ich möchte dir gar nicht in die Sendung reinreden, aber sag mir jetzt, wer wird der? Wer ist der größte deutsche Sportler außerhalb des Fußballs? Niemand braucht einen Fußballer als größten deutschen Sportler. Jetzt einfach aktuell aktiv, also Dirk ist raus.
Ist ganz schwierig, weil du hast ihn glaube ich genannt mit Leon Dreiseitel. Ich glaube im weltweiten Scope jetzt ja. Ich habe die Diskussion mal ganz kurz gestartet. Größter deutscher Sportler aller Zeiten. Führt für mich persönlich keinen Weg an Boris Becker vorbei, weil er eine Sportart auf die Landkarte gebracht hat, die davor nicht da war. Und wer sich erinnern kann, du bist ja zum Glück noch deutlich jünger als ich, aber 1985, da war ich gerade 15 Jahre alt, habe mich für Tennis interessiert. Und was da, das habe ich in Österreich mitbekommen, was da mit Decke abgegangen ist, ist Wahnsinn. Im Moment ist es wahrscheinlich wirklich Leon Dreiseitel und, aber wenn wir es global das Ganze sehen, das Dreiseitel war noch nicht in den Playoffs. Das Dreiseitel hat im vergangenen Jahr unfassbar es geschafft. Wenn wir das mal anschauen, in der Süddeutschen Zeitung, im Spiegel jetzt auch glaube ich im aktuellen Max Kepler, in einer Sportart, die in Deutschland komplett unpopulär ist, nämlich Baseball, aber Max Kepler hat im vergangenen Jahr 36 Homeruns, glaube ich, geschlagen, ist übrigens auch, weil wir drüber sprechen, Oliver Knack, der ihn getroffen hat im Spring Training, wo das noch nicht abseilbar war, schreibt über Max Kepler in diesem Magazin. Und dann haben wir natürlich auch wieder Dennis Schröder. Wir sind nur in Amerika. Aber wenn ich jetzt schaue und Alexander Zverev, ja, möglicherweise hat er weltweit schon den größten Bekanntheitsgrad mittlerweile. Weil im Tennis, und er war jetzt mit Federer auf einer Tour in Südamerika, die dem auch noch geholfen haben, natürlich war er der große Meister. Es ist ganz schwierig. Und wenn du jetzt einen Fußballer ansprechen würdest, ich tue mich mit Mannschaftssportler, jetzt habe ich drei Seite Kepler und Schröder sind Mannschaftssportler. Aber als Fußballspiel im Moment, da fehlt mir in Deutschland jemand, der wirklich herausragt. Und deshalb bei den German Power Rankings, was die Leistung angeht, wahrscheinlich Leon Dreiseitel im Moment. Und man muss ihn trotzdem bringen, weil er hat es ja wieder unter die besten acht Tennisspieler der Welt geschafft, auch wenn er in diesem Jahr noch ein Turnier gewonnen hat. Vielleicht Alexander Sverev.
Mit dem hätte ich tatsächlich jetzt nicht gerechnet, nach dem, was ich jetzt in dem Jahr gehört habe. Aber deswegen stelle ich ja diese Frage.
Ja, ich bin mir auch unsicher.
Und die Anschlussfrage führt dann über zum Wunsch. Ich wünsche mir nicht nur auf dem Cover, sondern ich wünsche mir mehr Frauen. Also in dem Heft ist es jetzt schon sehr männerlastig. Und deshalb die Frage, wer ist die größte Sportlerin Deutschlands aktuell?
Es ist immer noch Angele Kerber. Weil sie aufgrund ihrer dreifachen Majorsiegerin war Nummer eins der Welt. Und auch wieder die globale Wahrnehmung, weil ich jetzt...
Und das ist für dich da ein wichtiges Kriterium?
Das ist für mich schon ein wichtiges Kriterium, weil ich kann keine Leistungen vergleichen. Ich glaube, dass die deutsche Meisterin im Mehrkampf der Turnerinnen, die ich jetzt, und ich schäme mich dafür, nicht kenne, aber ich glaube, dass deren Leistung mindestens ebenso gut ist wie die von Inji Kerber. Und das Gleiche gilt für Fabian Hambüchen, dessen Leistung ich viel höher einschätze als jedes Bundesligafußballspiel. Dass nur jeder Drittlig ist mehr verdient als Fabian Hambüchen, das ist halt traurig. Aber ich glaube, dass im Damensport, gerade in Mannschaftssportarten, sich die Frauen extrem schwer tun. Also man muss wahrscheinlich, gerade was die öffentliche Wahrnehmung angeht, und da ist es für mich, Laura Dahlmeier, es ist einfach eine Sportart, mit der ich wenig anfangen kann mit Biathlon. Aber wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste und wir sagen, okay, Dahlmeier ist in diesem Jahr erst zurückgetreten, dann nehme ich Laura Dahlmeier vielleicht noch dazu. Ich nehme vielleicht aus olympischen Sporten eben die nicht genanme Konstanze Klosterhalven noch dazu, die über 5000 Meter Dritter geworden ist in Doha, aber bei der man wieder sagen muss, dieses ganze Nike Oregon Project, wer sich dafür interessiert, ganz, ganz schwierige Gemengelage. Also Max, du nagelst mich hier fest zurecht. Ich müsste immer noch sagen, auch weil sie sportlich interessant ist, immer noch finde ich, schafft sie nochmal ein Comeback, kann sie sich nochmal motivieren fürs nächste Jahr, weil im Tennissport gerade so viel passiert mit diesen vielen jungen Spielerinnen, kann Angie dann nochmal wirklich einen großen Titel gewinnen.
Ich würde noch Almut Schult reinwerfen. Da haben wir jetzt zwar auch eine Fußballerin mit drin, aber einfach weil ich sowohl finde, dass sie eine sehr gute WM gespielt hat, beim VfL Wolfsburg sowieso, also die spielen ja alles im Grund und Boden, national und international ja auch sehr häufig. Aber weil ich es auch einfach so wahnsinnig cool finde, die hat jetzt bekannt gegeben, dass sie schwanger ist und deswegen ihre Karriere unterbricht. Und das, finde ich, ist so ein mutiger Schritt. Noch mal viel mutiger als wenn das ein Mann, der es ja nicht machen muss, machen würde, weil die Männer ja so viel mehr verdienen. Die können sich das viel eher erlauben, damit auch die Gefahr zu gehen, dass die Karriere danach vielleicht nicht wieder gleich so weiterläuft, wie es vorher war. Auf der Höhe ihres Schaffens entscheidet sie sich, dazu ein Kind zu bekommen, ihre Karriere zu unterbrechen. Aber woran liegt das? Dass wir so viel seltener über Frauen im Sport sprechen. Obwohl wir zwar ja schon Menschen sind, denen das ja auch bewusst ist, die auch versuchen manchmal gegenzusteuern. Und trotzdem kommen wir auch quasi qua der Struktur unserer Sendung dazu.
Ja, ich muss mich ja selbst an der Nase nehmen. Wo spreche ich über Frauensport? Und das ist im Tennis und das ist im Skifahren. Weil im Skifahren gibt es mit Michaela Schifrin im Moment, die wird alle Rekorde brechen. Aber so bin ich einfach als Österreicher gepolt. Das ist halt, wie du es halt lernst von deinen Eltern, finde ich. Und wie es auch meinem Sohn vor allen Dingen. Wir sitzen halt da und dann schauen wir uns zuerst den Herrn-Stallarm an und dann den Frauens-Stallarm oder umgekehrt, was er zuerst kommt. Aber ich glaube, es liegt am Publikum im Grunde genommen. Und wenn wir mal schauen, die Sky-Abonnenten, die sich das Sky-Abo kaufen oder das Dazone-Abo, sind wahrscheinlich, wenn es wegen des Sportes ist, dann sind es wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich Männer. Und vielleicht ist das Interesse. Ich habe die Diskussion gestern, ich bin ja nebenbei auch noch Lehrer, in meinen Klassen geführt und habe gesagt, ist es legitim, dass weibliche Tennisspieler sagen, sie müssen gleich viel verdienen wie männliche Tennisspieler? Ich stelle die Frage dir, Max.
Ich finde, ja. Es kommt auf die Art des Einkommens an. Sponsoren und so weiter, die kannst du nie dazu zwingen, was sie ihren Tennisspielern zahlen. Ich finde aber, überall, wo ein Verband Geld zahlt und diese Verbände haben einen gesellschaftlichen Auftrag, die sind nicht einfach so da, das sind keine privaten Unternehmen mit Erfolgsinteressen, da fände ich es zwingend maßgeblich, dass männliche Sportler genauso viel bekommen wie Männer. Die weiblichen Sportler, bzw. eher, man muss es ja umgedreht formulieren, da haben wir einen öffentlichen Auftrag, einen Sinn für die Gesellschaft. Alles andere ist schwer zu beeinflussen.
Da bin ich völlig bei dir, wenn es darum geht. Also wenn der Deutsche Turner Bund für einen Weltmeistertitel 10.000 Euro auslobt, dann kann es nicht sein, dass es bei den Herren 12.000 sind und bei den Frauen 8.000. Aber ansonsten entscheidet der freie Markt für mich. Man kann nicht den Tennisturnier Nürnberg vorschreiben, du musst gleich viel zahlen wie das Tennisturnier in München, aber dann gibt es das Tennisturnier in Nürnberg nicht mehr, weil es dort keine Sponsoren gibt. Und in München gibt es BMW, die das subventionieren. Andersherum könnte ich auch argumentieren, dass der Tenor in der Wiener Staatsoper gleich viel verdienen muss wie Anna Netrebko. Nur die Leute kaufen sich die Eintrittskarte wegen Anna Netrebko.
Das stimmt natürlich. Auf der anderen Seite erleben wir gerade sehr gut, wo es einen hinbringt, wenn man den freien Markt einfach mal machen lässt.
Du hast mich überzeugt, stoppen wir den freien Markt. Aber erst, wenn ihr das Hashtag 12 Monate gekauft habt, dann stoppen wir den freien Markt.
steilpasssportradio360.de ist die Mail-Adresse. Da erfahrt ihr alles Weitere. Kauft euch für einen 20er beide Hefte.
Sehr schön. Übrigens sachnienlicher Hinweis, gebt mir bitte gleich eine Adresse an, wo das Heft hingeschickt werden soll. Hilft mir, hilft der Deutschen Post, hilft euch auch.
Es ist tatsächlich der Sache dienlich. Also besser wurde dieses Adverb in diesem Fall. Ja, glaube ich. Nee, adjektiv ist das Quatsch. Ganz normal ist adjektiv. Ja, siehste, da geht's schon dahin bei mir. Aber das macht auch die Auszeit mit einem. Man rostet ein.
Nee, man wird viel frischer dann. Nach 10 Minuten wird man viel, viel frischer.
Also ich find's krass, was du da wieder auf die Beine gestellt hast. Ich fürchte um dein Wohlbefinden, weil ich fast schon Angst habe, dass du zur EM wieder so ein Mammutprojekt stellen wirst. Nage dich jetzt bitte nicht drauf fest.
Ich bin im nächsten Jahr hin und hergerissen. Weil, wie ich sage, wir pflegen einen Olympischen Ansatz. Tokyo 2020. Ich bin hin und hergerissen, auf was ich mich da stürzen soll.
Also ich fände das nicht-Fußballerische immer interessanter als den Fußball. Weil Fußball machen alle.
Eben.
Sagt natürlich der Typ, der dann auch wieder Tänkliche Tendung machen wird. Aber ich versuch's ja wenigstens ein bisschen anders zu machen als andere. Aber genau das ist es. Und diese EM wird sowieso ganz merkwürdig werden. Merkt man ja jetzt schon an der Art und Weise der Qualifikation und so weiter. Da hat sich was verschoben, was eben einfach damals ausgelöst wurde durch Michel Platini, der gerne gewählt worden werden wollte und dafür quasi ein komplettes Turnier schon ein bisschen in dem Sinne, wie man es bisher kennt, den Charakter des Turniers hat er geopfert für seine Wiederwahl. Alle wussten es aber auch. Jetzt ist es nur auf einmal so, dass es auch die Öffentlichkeit wahrnimmt, dass man auf einmal so diese Bruchstellen sieht und jetzt ist es aber zu spät. Jetzt werden wir auch im Baku auf jeden Fall spielen.
Ja, aber die Deutschen begriffen es ja nicht, weil die Deutschen in der astfreien Allianz-Arena spielen werden und die Österreicher, ich weiß gar nicht, wo die Österreicher dann unterkommen.
Hat sich Österreich qualifiziert? Nein, es war ein Bitz.
Mit Aach und Graf mit einem Start in 0 zu 1 in Lettland zum Abschluss. Es ist wirklich Hanebüchen.
Es ist wirklich ein Jammer, aber solange es nicht wieder so sein wird, wie beim letzten Turnier von Österreich, dass sich David Alaba eigentlich quasi einer eigenen Wirkmacht immer weiter vor ins Feld schiebt und irgendwann Zehner spielt.
Ja, aber dann zu feig ist, zum Elfmeter anzutreten und den Sportskameraden Dragovic vorschickt, der natürlich die Kugel nicht reintrifft. So schaut es aus.
So schaut es nämlich aus. Also, 12 Monate. Kauft euch 12 Monate, hört das Sportradio360. Ihr könnt Jens und das Sportradio auch unabhängig von dieser Zeitschrift unterstützen. Ich kann es sehr empfehlen. Es schadet nicht. Macht unsere Podcastlandschaft bunter.
Und freut mich sehr natürlich. steinpassettsportradio360.de Sehr gut.
Ich würde sagen, Jens, vielen Dank dir, dass du hier warst. Vielen Dank euch lieben Hörern und Hörern für die Aufmerksamkeit. Mal gucken, wann es mit den Kurzpassen wieder regulär weitergeht. Gebt uns da bitte noch ein bisschen Zeit. Wir haben nämlich aktuell auch noch ein anderes Thema am Rasenfunk, was sehr viele Ressourcen frisst. Ihr werdet hoffentlich in der nächsten Woche, wenn ihr das jetzt aktuell hört, schon mehr wissen. Drückt uns einfach die Daumen, dass das hinhaut. Und dann euch eine schöne Woche. Bis bald mal wieder im Rasenfunk.